[Musique]
on a dit de vous que vous étiez le
précurseur de l'érotisme
si j'étais le précurseur l'érotisme bon
alain je serai pina vieux
[Musique]
dès son premier film et dieu créa la
femme de roger vadim fut célèbre
il devait aussi l'un des réalisateurs
français les plus contestées qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le scandale qu'est ce
qu'on appelle choqué pour beaucoup de
gens c'est de dire les choses d'une
façon qui les surprend qu'elle ne
s'attende pas c'est à dire les dire au
fond sans hypocrisie dans cette mesure
oui je dois dire que je trouve que
choquer tu me qualité et les votre moral
la droite nous avons nous là j'en perds
ma cigarette ma morale c'est de ne pas
agresser les autres pour le dire en
quelques mots de plus agir librement
sans influence et ceux qui ne veulent
pas être influencée et sans imposer ses
idées aux autres
à moins que ces îles ne soit reçu
volontairement dans le fond cela
moraliste un moraliste quelqu'un qui
traite de la morale qui discutent de la
morale qui refuse la morale
traditionalistes et qui donne en exemple
sa propre morale je rêve d'une société
où la morale soit faite d'élégance de
justice
j'ai un peu et humaniste et de courage
il faut évidemment lutter bien longtemps
pour ça je ne suis pourtant pas un
utopiste mais le sens du péché
cette forme puritaine qui vous oblige à
trouver une justification au fait qu'on
existe au fait qu'on a du plaisir est
terrible elle conditionne tous les êtres
humains et on parle toujours du monde
libre face au monde
socialistes communistes mais d'abord il
faudrait que ce monde libre se
débarrasse de la morale chrétienne faut
d'abord qu'il n'y a plus ce sens
abominable du péché alors on dit si on
n'a pas le sens du péché on tue tout le
monde
ce n'est pas vrai la criminalité existe
bien autant dans les sociétés qui ont le
sens de la culpabilité que dans les
autres alors voila moi je suis contre la
morale qui vous oblige à vous
considérait toujours comme un criminel
je suis pour la morale qui vous donne la
liberté d'agir d'être heureux d mais
d'avoir du plaisir que ce soit d'adorer
la forêt deux jours avec les petits
oiseaux où que ce soit je devrais avoir
honte du plaisir
[Musique]